العمليه العسكريه الاسرائيليه حدثت الساعه
العاشره صباحا كان هناك مقاتلان من عرين
الاسود يتحصنان في هذا البيت عندما
داهمتهم قوه اسرائيليه خاصه كانت تتذكر
بلباس رجال دين وكانت ايضا تحمل الاسلحه
سرعان ما حاصرت الشبان في هذه الغرفه
وقامت بقصف الغرفه بالصواريخ بعد ان رفض
المقاتلان تسليم انفسهم القوات
الاسرائيليه اشتباكات عنيفه دارت في محيط
هذا المنزل وهذا المكان في البلده القديمه
في مدينه
نابلس قام شبان فلسطيني برشق القوات
الاسرائيليه بالحجاره اضافه لانضمام عدد
ايضا اخر من المقاتلين من مدينه نابلس في
محاوله لصد الهجوم الاسرائيلي على هذه
المدينه نزلوا درجات جامع الكبير شيوخ
يعني كبار بالسن مشوا معهم سجاده في
الشفات على الحوش
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه فان حصيله هذا
الهجوم الاسرائيلي على مدينه نابلس وصلت
الى 10 الضحايا من بينهم تجار فلسطينيين
كبار في العمر يتجاوز عمرهم السبعين عاما
كانوا يتواجدوا هنا في هذا المكان في
متاجرهم واشغالهم اليوميه اضافه الى
الضحايا من الاطفال هذه الحصيله مرشحه
للارتفاع نظرا لوجود نحو 100 جريح بعضهم
اصابته خطره كان اي واحد يحاول انه يطول
يحاول يطول اي جريح او اي شهيد كانوا
مباشره
زي قناص يعني ما يضرب حواليه انه ينبهه
اصابات مباشره ردود فعل شعبيه فلسطينيه
غاضبه على هذا الهجوم الاسرائيلي الذي
يوصف بالاكثر دمويه منذ بدايه هذا العام
الفصائل الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
اعلنت الاضراب والحداد العام على ارواح
الضحايا في مهدده الفصائل وفي غزه بالرد
على هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي الذي وصفته
بالخطير اما سياسيا فامين سر اللجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه حسين الشيخ وصف ما جرى
بالمجزره ودعا لتوفير حمايه دوليه
للفلسطينيين فيما قال رئيس الوزراء محمد
اشتيا ان اسرائيل تحاول تصدير ازماتها
السياسيه الداخليه الى الساحه الفلسطينيه
العشرات من المسلحين يشاركون في هذا
التشييع مع دعوات للرد على اسرائيل
بعمليات عسكريه مماثله من مدينه نابلس عبد
الحفيظ جوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه